[Applause]
president putin has put his nuclear
deterrence forces on high alert i
ordered the minister of defense
and the chief of general staff
to put
determined forces
of the russian army
on special
combat standby duty
that means the kremlin's nuclear weapons
operators will be primed and ready to
attack at short notice if president
putin decides it's necessary it's
basically down to putin whether or not
to launch the nuclear weapons and he has
constant access to a briefcase called
the cheget from which he can launch the
weapons in response to a crisis
do you think he's crazy enough to
instigate a nuclear conflict i'm not
going to speculate on what he would or
wouldn't do but that's why we all keep
our deterrence at a state of readiness
in the west to make sure that we can
deter the world's use of nuclear weapons
is kept in check by a concept called
mutually assured destruction
the idea is fairly simple and works on
the assumption that the risk of
retaliation from one nuclear power
against another would be so devastating
it ensures two nuclear powers would
never in reality attack one another
however the theory doesn't hold for a
nuclear state attacking a non-nuclear
power
globally there are five states
officially recognised as possessing
nuclear weapons by the non-proliferation
treaty that's an international treaty
designed to prevent the spread of
nuclear weapons the five countries are
also the permanent five members of the
un security council china france russia
the us and the united kingdom in january
2022 they all pledged to prevent atomic
weapons from spreading and to ensure a
nuclear war is never fought
there's also a handful of countries that
have nuclear weapons that aren't signed
up to the treaty these are believed to
include india israel pakistan and north
korea
but more than 90 percent of the world's
nuclear warheads belong to russia and
the united states
each country has their own types of
nuclear weapons and different ways to
deliver them the uk's nuclear deterrent
called trident uses four vanguard-class
nuclear-powered submarines this means
that every hour of every day at least
one is at sea ready to launch an attack
if ordered the us uses submarines bomber
planes and intercontinental missiles
which briefly leave the earth's
atmosphere when fired they have more
than five and a half thousand weapons
russia has even more than the us with
more than six 000 nuclear weapons they
can be launched from submarines bomber
planes and intercontinental missiles but
the country also distinguishes between
different types of nuclear warfare in a
way that others don't
vladimir putin's latest nuclear threat
is a departure from established russian
nuclear deterrence doctrine in 2020
putin approved basic principles with
four cases where moscow could use
nuclear weapons
they were when ballistic missiles were
fired at russia or allies territory
when an enemy used nuclear weapons an
attack on a russian nuclear weapons site
or an attack threatening the existence
of the russian state none of those
criteria has been met so far in the
current conflict
but the doctrine also allows for smaller
tactical nuclear warheads to be
threatened in a conventional conflict
including against a non-nuclear armed
country such as ukraine in the hope that
the other side capitulates in fear it's
referred to as escalate to de-escalate
in this context they might use a small
nuclear weapon in ukraine but given nato
has not intervened so far with the
military response this seems very
unlikely ukraine has no nuclear weapons
after decommissioning them in 1994 in
return for security guarantees now being
ripped up by russia in return for
decommissioning their nuclear weapons
which they inherited when the ussr
disintegrated they were told russia and
the west would guarantee their security
this was called the budapest memorandum
nuclear weapons have only been used
twice over hiroshima and nagasaki during
the second world war
the devastation and suffering they
caused helped bring the second world war
to an end but have spurred calls for
disarmament in the years ever since
putin's warned interference in his
military campaign in ukraine could lead
to consequences that you have never
encountered in your history as he put it
widely regarded as a thinly veiled
threat to use nuclear weapons
that in his willingness to put his
nuclear weapons on increased readiness
so early in the conflict is causing
considerable concern
in the west as with so much of this
conflict it lies in the hands of
vladimir putin